I'm not I'm not trying to click bait you
I'm not I don't edit it out I know you
guys are just walking into this I don't
expect you to have the hot bags I just I
just like to understand like why you
believe it but you not understand our
Point like the people that are against
it do you not understand their point of
view I think their point of view is
often it's my body my choice right but
I'm saying when you take that to the
extreme it doesn't make sense have you
had sex bro I'm not a virgin so you've
had sex what have you had a baby but I
was I was nobody here so so so here's
the thing here's the thing one if I got
pregnant I would keep it because to me
like I I don't believe in abortion and I
have um I have I have a brother right
and my mom got pregnant when she was a
teenager and she gave him up for
adoption and so to me it's like do you
think that's life that's a life adoption
usually kids that are in adopted care
it's not a good life in that sense no he
had a great life he's married pregnant